[Music]  June they're coming to you out of love  you understand that I'm staying with my  sister and that's not my choice  I swear to god mama it's not my choice a  way is not yes it is because you said  it's not much what she wants to stay  with you she obviously doesn't feel safe  in the house tell you about my day but I  can't do that because I'm scared I'm not  gonna lie to you I'm scared to figure  out they didn't even face her  I mean Alana's crying this is not who  June is yeah got your children crying  telling you to get it together we're  here for you you need help I don't know  she's just numb or totally delusional  about what she's seeing us trying to do  [Applause]  you  [Music]